Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du der neue Papst-Fan? Bist du ein neuer Papst-Fan? Bist du immer noch Papst-Fan? Du hast dich ja wohlwollend geäußert.
So schnell kann man das noch nicht sagen. Ich bin erst mal erfreut darüber, dass ein Papst sich Leo XIV nennt, denn das bezieht sich natürlich auf eine lange Leo-Tradition. Vor allem knüpft er ja dann wohl an, an Leo XIII. Das war der Papst.
Meinst du?
Ja, das macht man schon aus Gründen.
Leo XIV schließt an Leo XIII an, kann sein.
Ja, das möchte man. Also man möchte in einer Tradition stehen.
Ich wollte wegen den Zahlen machen, aber du hast nämlich recht. Man kann auch an andere Leones anschließen.
Man möchte an Leo XIII anschließen. Der Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts, ja, der erste Papst, der eine Sozialenzyklika rausgegeben hat. Also das, was dann später auch katholische Soziallehre genannt wurde, das ist die Reaktion der katholischen Kirche. Sicherlich auch auf den Sozialismus, auf Marx und die Folgenden. Nicht, dass ich jetzt ein riesengroßer Fan der katholischen Soziallehre bin. Ich sehe da natürlich aus marxistischer Perspektive durchaus Schwierigkeiten. Aber was natürlich wichtig ist, ist, dass das ein Papst ist, der das Soziale in den Mittelpunkt rückt, der eine hoffentlichen Kirchenpolitik auch für die Armen machen wird und der damit auch ein Stachel im Fleisch sein wird. All jener, die jetzt gerade gratulieren, wie zum Beispiel Donald Trump. Also, dass er mit Donald Trump viel gemein hat, danach sieht es jetzt gerade nicht aus und das ist ja schon mal erfreulich.